مره اخرى وبعيدا عن الاضواء تنجح
الاولويات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه في
اختراق جدار القطيعه الامريكي الروسي الذي
فاقمته الحرب على اوكرانيا
العاصمتان واشنطن و موسكو اكدتا ان لقاء
ان يجمع في انقره مديره وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه سيايييه ويليامبرز مع
رئيس جهاز المخابرات الخارجيه الروسيه
سيرجينار شكين وكاي اجتماع امني يتحفظ
الجانبان عن التفاصيل لكن ما تسرب على
الامريكيين يشير الى ان بيرز ذهب الى
تركيا لا من اجل التفاوض لتسويه الحرب في
اوكرانيا بل لتحذير الروس من عواقب
استخدام اسلحه النوويه وخطر التصعيد على
الاستقرار الاستراتيجي اما الكريم فاعلن
ان محادثات انقره تعقد بمبادره من
الولايات المتحده وانها تجري بضيافه جهاز
الاستخبارات التركي
تكن الحيثيات فالواضح ان قنوات التواصل
السريه بين موسكو وواشنطن باتت حقيقه
تتخطى حاله التدهور المعلن في العلاقات
الثنائيه منذ الهجوم الروسيه على اوكرانيا
ف قبل ايام كشف مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيكسوليفان عن انخراطه في
محادثات سريه مع مسؤولينا روس كبار
للحيلوله دون تصعيد النووي لكن جهود اداره
المخاطر تلك لا تبدو منفصله عن جهود
امريكيه حفيفه لايجاد تسويه للحرب في
اوكرانيا وهي رغبه تتنامها هذه الايام في
اروقه صنع القرار في واشنطن صحيفه ولستريد
جورنال الامريكيه نقلت عن مصادر مطلعه ان
سلفان ابلغ الرئيس الاوكراني خلال لقائه
في كيف بضروره الانفتاح على المفاوضات لان
كيف ستكتسب نفوزا من خلال اظهار تحيا على
التفاوض
وذكرت الصحيفه ان المستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي اوصى جيلنسكي وفريقه بالبدئ في
التفكير في مطالب واقعيه وباولويات
التفاوض بما في ذلك اعاده النظر في الهدف
المعلن المتمثل باستعاده اوكرانيا شبه
جزيره القرم حتى الان تتمسكوا كيف بموقفها
وتشترط استعاده كل الاراضي قبل اي حوار مع
موسكو لكن تطورات الاوضاع وتبدل المعطيات
بما فيها ربما تزايد ضغطي واشنطن ومزيد من
التقارب الامريكي الروسي قد يقنع
الاوكرانيين باعاده ترتيب اولوياتهم لا
سيما بعد المكاسب الميدانيه التي يحققها
هجومهم المضاد في شرق البلاد وجنوبها